Okay, what is the benefit of grounding? Should I use a grounding sheet?
Well, that's an interesting question because I have a grounding sheet right here. So
first of all, most people know what grounding is. I remember talking about grounding 10 years ago or so and everybody's like, what are you talking about grounding?
Most people have heard what grounding is. So what grounding is basically helping discharge positive
ions off your body. That's basically what grounding is. You know, we live in a world where there's, you know, how can I turn out a radio with a little antenna and I can get all these different stations because there's radio waves going through us right now. Does that damage our body?
I don't know. Does it add a charge to our body? Yeah, I think so. I'm sitting in front of a computer screen. If you're watching me, you're sitting in front of the computer screen or your telephone. Those are EFS. Those are charged. These are electrical frequencies.
They're electrical charge. And these electrical charge stay on our body and in our cells on our surface of our tissue, our skin, and they need to discharge. So grounding is walking outside in your feet and touching the ground and you're discharging those positively charged protons.
The earth is balanced in its electrical charge and it can definitely give away some electrons to balance you out. And that's what grounding is. That's a benefit of, you know, having animals that are walking around with four feet on the ground and you go and pet the animal. You're basically discharging your
positively charged EFS to the person, to the dog, to the horse, to the cat, whatever it is. That's the benefit of pets. So, especially in cold areas and cold climates, how do you ground it? I'm not going to walk around outside in January in my bare feet. Well, some people do, but I don't think I will. Well, you could use grounding instruments. Your house is grounded. Hopefully, unless you live in an old house and your electrical outlets are grounded.
We have a little testing device. So in our grounding sheet that we sell, we have the little testing devices to make sure you're what's our ground because if you plug this sheet into an outlet that's not grounded, it's going to work. So I'm going to do anything. So the idea is in grounding using a grounding sheet or a grounding map or something like that.
You are you are plugging it into a grounded outlet, the ground, the third crawl of an outgrown outlet. That goes back for via a copper wire back to your your electrical box and then it connects to a made ground bar that that's connected to a heavier cable.
Copper cable that goes outside and connects to the ground. So you're basically grounded like walking outside, but using your grounding of your electrical and your house.
Your house is older. You don't have any three prone outlets or you use a device like this and none of your three health that's are actually connected correctly or ground ground.
You may need to call an electrician first and make sure that that is done. But you can easily check it with this.
If you don't buy a grounding sheet for us, you can buy one of these at your local hardware store for less than $10 or get about Amazon.
It just checks if your outlets are grounded. And then a grounding sheet is a material that has a little wires in it basically that then this snaps on to a cable that connects to that third crawl of a grounded outlet.
And that's how you get grounded. So the benefit of using a grounding sheet is you're basically grounded yourself all night.
It's hugely beneficial. So our grounding sheets that we have made specifically for us are half sheets. So they only go on the lower half of the bed.
Well, why is that? Because there's a whole bunch of grounding sheets out these days that are full sheets that cover your full mattress.
And isn't that better? Well, yes and no. So when we have patients that are using a rife machine, using rife technology,
are trying to get good frequencies in them. We don't want those good frequencies to just disperse through the grounding sheet back to the ground outside through your wiring.
So I only tell people to only put it on the bottom half of their bed.
It's like you don't need to go outside to ground. You just stand in your bare feet. You're discharging those positive charged
protons. You don't need to go hung up the ground. So you just need a part of you touching that grounding sheet that's
going to help disperse those negative charges. So grounding is great. I tell you there's thousands of
testimonials of people that have had arthritis issues to migrate issues to whatever you name it. It could
have to do with the frequencies that you're picking up all these negative EMFs that you pick it up. I mean, people think
of EMFs is oh, they can cause cancer. They can cause brain cancer. They can cause all sorts of ill health. So
grounding yourself is really beneficial. So maybe it's one of the reasons why I love to guard it. A lot of
people love to guard it. I just like to get their hands dirty. Will you grounding yourself? That's why
you feel calmer when you guard it usually. Maybe not this time of year. I feel agrier. Sometimes you don't
know what to do, but that's another story.